paul
[Musique]
sur le rempart de saint-paul lorsque le
goudron s'arrêtent les pavés font
apparaître trois cents ans d'histoire
franck est en vacances à la réunion mais
originaire de saint paul il apprécie le
moment c'est notre histoire un petit peu
le patrimoine c'est bien été rénovés
comme il faut ça nous fait plaisir de
monter jusqu ici que les pulls efforts
accomplis connaissez l'histoire le
compte de l'élément chi de retint les
porter nous on a du mal à porter notre
corps il me fait chier les gens qui
pensaient les messieurs un peu du nôtre
tient à organiser des animations
culturelles
je ne fais des visites guidées aussi
pendant ma l'école mais le département
et nous accompagne sur les contrats et
8,6 à et puis un petit peu pour le
fonctionnement 7 niveaux aujourd'hui
tout ça mon coeur parce que c'est un
travail que nous a fait pendant 20 ans
et qu'on va et nous là tandis ce moment
là parce que la france réhabiliter le
chemin me dit bon il faut un joueur qui
arrive 2019 ben le chemin nous nous les
landes marque le coup 2010 nef et le
joual arrivé aujourd'hui
la foule empruntent les 2 km 400 de ce
sentier qui plonge dans l'espace naturel
de l'étang saint paul des stands ont été
placés tout au long du chemin pour
l'occasion comme si revivez cet axe
essentiel entre les hauts et les bas
mais en moi même on s'est battu poitiers
à l'état qu'il faut mettre unia des
contrats aidés
j'ai fait on amènera ici des
personnalités de l'état au montana pour
ça on est capable de faire part d'un
danois pet moyens une journée magnifique
ponctuée de chants et de danses car
personne ne semblait vouloir oublier
cette partie de notre histoire
ici vous avez des nos ancêtres qui ont
travaillé pour réaliser le chemin pavé
aujourd'hui son chemin sont devenus pour
nous une résonance partie du passé pour
l'avenir parce que ici maintenant
vous avez aussi un développement
touristique voilà les pirates vie
avec un tel dynamisme ce vecteur de lien
social a encore de beaux jours devant
lui
[Musique]